so our process these like little cards
right it's 300 gigabytes worth of tiny
SD cards dump all the footage separate
the footage into different folders for
each take six different files for take
one then go into video stitch drop all
those files sync it up stitch it up
match the color export your shots now
you have a 360 shot that looks like this
from here you download this tool from
YouTube called that one thing it injects
360 metadata into your file takes
literally about 20 seconds upload that
three-two-one it looks back the rest of
the afternoon trying to replicate my
success I got hit it doing this one Roy
let your natural spin occur and so for
example it's hitting handle first try
doing back to feet and then I'll
probably hit blade first coding little
buddy
just want to fly it siffredi built a
drone flying for fun I thought that'd be
really cool
I thought Friday my could race so I have
a problem with my drone it was so close
to working I had one bad part and I
swapped that part out and now none of it
works don't know what to do I happen to
be one of the lucky few people on the
planet have a youtube channel with
multiple hundreds of thousand
subscribers and if any of you guys know
anything about building these drones and
want to help me out this problem I would
greatly appreciate it I promise you I
will make some sick drone flying videos
like you see how those crazy Russians
doing it'll be the best it'll be the
best if one of them is good the other
one is bad and we can put the good one
in we can install windows we can get
things working for right now we have two
there they were rated to get one of them
right now is being run through a test
they both refurbished yes they are both
refurbish
neither of us are good at that we got
c-max in that house God is your hands Oh
what was that
Hey turning blue yes I pulled my neck
can you do it all right Johnny you got
this you guys I'm such a kid now